Tại cố lập bộ thảo luận văn đại ở thành phố SOT 2,
tổng thống phút chiến lửa dựa gia quan điểm về một loại cấp vấn đề liên quan tính
a cũng như quan hệ giữa ngà với cân lớt lớn và về cuộc xung độ tại Utrena.
Đáng chuyến, nhà lĩnh đạo ngà chuyến bố, nước này đang chứng cách khô phục phần dễ quan hệ với bí
ông bây to tý tụi, và Mỹ sẽ đặt được thoại hiệp xung của điều bất đồng.
Sao tổng thống khu tiền cho rằng quan hệ xung phương có thể sẽ bị anh hồng lớn,
nếu Utrena sử dụng tên lửa hành chính đồng hó,
gió Mỹ cũng cấp để tình công lãnh thống ngà.
Ông bù chiến cũng cạnh báo Utrena đang mạo hiệp khi tình công khu vực cân nhà mấy hát nhân giả
của ríc nhà và cho biết mắt xe và có thể tình công đáp trả các cơ sửa hành nhiên
của Utrena.
Fê quan hệ vinh đã tố, dơ lãnh đạo ngà nhìn này,
mắt xe đáp trả mạnh mẽ và nhìn trong nếu bị hiểu khíc về quân sửa.
Hoa ra, tổng thống buồn chiến điều gió,
vyu bảo vệ của lập ngà bằng các biển phó triv và đá thức bài,
và các bê liên quan đá nhận ra rằng điều không có ngà,
không thể đáp được sự cân bằng trong bất kỳ điện phục ngà.
Bà buổi của naïtím,
bây giờ,
naïtím.